histoire-géographie sport et cours sur
l'actualité les matières calassanes
affectionnent le plus pourtant autrefois
il était peu assidu aux activités
scolaires et s'est retrouvées en échec
et puis voilà quoi c'était plus ça aussi
je faisais j'ai pas fait les efforts
nécessaires avant donc du coup j'étais
largué l'exemple du frère d'Alassane
passé par l'école de la deuxième chance
à convaincu sa maman d'orienter son fils
cadet vers cette voix
la volonté qui est qui que j'avais pas
avant aujourd'hui à la salle souhaite
devenir animateur son parcours un schéma
classique pour ses élèves de l'école de
la deuxième chance de Trappes ouverte en
2007 une école qui s'adresse aux jeunes
entre 18 et 25 ans sortie du système
scolaire depuis plus d'un an et sans
diplôme ni qualification ici les
enseignements classiques sont dispensés
pour une remise à niveau en plus de la
découverte du monde de l'entreprise il
s'adapte à nous en fait c'est
avec nous il nous suit chacun c'est
individualisé
pas de classe surchargée les formateurs
sont à l'écoute un processus qui
encourage les élèves leur parcours ici
ce n'est qu'une étape et qu'ils doivent
se projeter loin très loin voilà c'est
ça qui est ça qu'on apprend ici surtout
l'idée est au bout de 10 mois de
formation ou plutôt si c'est possible il
poursuivent leur parcours soit en emploi
directement soit sur un établissement de
formation si le métier qu'il vise
nécessite une formation avec une
première attestation de compétences
remise deux fois par an 70% des élèves
ici à Trappes obtiennent un emploi ou
s'oriente vers une formation
professionnelle plus poussée